oculus rift and virtual reality is sort
of the oculus rift being an example that
virtual reality has now arrived you know
multiple billion dollar purchase of
oculus rift shows that now they have the
resources to bring this thing into the
mainstream and of course virtual reality
like other media technologies like
cinema is an engine of empathy with you
know with an imax with a movie theater
the size of the screen the surround
sound audio puts you there with the
oculus rift potentially you're
surrounded now by the media by the
simulated dreamscape so you are even
more there so when I say an agent of
empathy the UN just released a virtual
reality film of a Syrian refugee camp
you know the fact that we're able to put
reporters now virtually on the ground is
it elicits a sort of experience that is
so much more visceral so much more
powerful that the elusive sense of
presence that literally puts you in a
liminal trance state your defenses get
lowered you forget yourself you forget
your problems you are there you are in
the moment and so you know the power of
that as an as an engine of empathy I
think can't hurt humanity you know I
think it's like they talk in the movie
interstellar our empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight and I think
with virtual reality and the oculus rift
we now are extending our line of sight
by being able to go everywhere at the
speed of mind and I think that's
transformational furthermore the
psychoneurotic philosopher terence
mckenna says that the goal of humanity
is to turn ourselves inside out right
and he says that with virtual reality
the canvas for inter subjective intimacy
is taken to the next level you know
before if i want to share the contents
of my mind I smile and I move my lips in
a certain way I make crude little grunts
to convey meanings I might make a
painting you know or might write a poem
and the point is these are a rich
tapestry of tools that human beings have
used for achieving something akin to
telepathy to know each other's minds to
enter the intersubjective space of one
another but with virtual reality each of
us potential
the full flowering of this technology
means each of us can create a universe
of our own construction a universe that
reflects our own archetypical spaces you
know our own iconography we turn
ourselves inside out you don't just come
into my room and see my books to see who
i am now you get to come inside my mind
that's what kind of blows my mind the
new spaces of intimacy that will be made
possible when you can invite your lover
or your friend into your world come
visit my world and you get to inhabit
that as a sort of Kosmos of the mind